foreign
Brands you uh when you and I first
connected you told me about one of your
favorite Brands uh and I'd love to hear
from you because quite often on your
Instagram which I really enjoy your
Instagram you will do the thing that I
often refuse to do you will highlight
the brands that you have yeah which is
smart because people are otherwise just
going to ask you what table is that what
chair is that that's my DMs yeah yeah so
Muji is my all-time favorite brand this
shirt is from there and Muji means no
brand in Japanese so you know you're
never going to see like Nike like Muji
or anything like that and it's all
really versatile thoughtful simple stuff
that can blend with anyone's home decor
and they've been around since the 80s
and a lot of their Storage Solutions
have been around since the 80s so it's
true Timeless design with no excess
people are always like Kristen you
should design a line of products and I'm
like well Muji already did it so that
would be unnecessary I also love Ikea I
think you with any store you have to be
selective there are good designs there
and there are bad designs and then I
really love Design Within Reach
specifically the Scandinavian Brands
like hey
um we had the the pleasure of going to
Sweden and Denmark and Norway and the
culture there is so minimalist like
their their values I don't know if y'all
have been but you would love it if not
yeah but I bet yeah often when when I
see any sort of Scandinavian design it's
it's hyper simple it's functional but
also it's beautiful their whole culture
is that way like their their value the
way they value people and the way that
they value sustainability and work-life
balance it's beautiful yeah but you can
follow Minima on Instagram as well we'll
put a link to your Instagram handle on
the show notes they can find all of the
uh the brands that you enjoy over there
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free